je pense que le politique toujours tort
de vouloir avoir raison tout le temps et
qu'il ya un moment il faut savoir
accepter qu'on a comme une erreur qu'on
s'est trompé le tout c'est de le dire et
de dire qu'on va le corriger et à
corriger effectivement fera tous les
français sont parfaitement capables de
comprendre cela personne n'est
absolument parfait mais vouloir à tout
prix ne jamais reconnaître ces
difficultés créée en réalité un élément
de défiance donc il faut sortir de ces
postulats
[Musique]
en réalité il ya plusieurs raisons à
l'échec de cette soirée foot de football
la première c'est qu'une mauvaise
anticipation mauvaise préparation
des décisions
de dernière minute qui ont été
contreproductives en particulier
concernant la grève du rer b au delà de
ça il est incontestable que la
responsabilité principale cible devient
d'avoir une relève sur les points de
sécurité car la fédération française de
football par exemple avait proposé un
jalonnement à l'arrivée des supporters
pour
diversifier les flux ce que la
préfecture a refusé et de fait
immédiatement il ya eu des difficultés
la deuxième chose a été mis en place un
système de pré filtrage c'est à dire
qu'on a mis les stades i en dehors du
stade et la police à l'arrière sauf que
c'est un système qui n'avait pas
fonctionné dans une compétition
précédente c'avait été constatés on l'a
maintenu quand même pour ce maître de
champion s league et ça n'a évidemment
pas fonctionné et puis en termes de
sécurité toujours c'est la grande
problématique de la gestion de la police
à savoir la priorité donnée au maintien
de l'ordre par rapport à la sécurité
publique ça veut dire que les services
qui étaient là étaient là pour protéger
de la foule s'est faite très court mais
en revanche n'a pas poursuivi les
délinquants qui ont sévi pa le soir même
mais dès la mi journée sur le territoire
malheureusement le la préfecture police
ne s'était pas armé si je puis dire pour
voir lutter contre
nous souhaitons une responsabilité
unique d'un organisateur parfaitement
identifiés qui est la maîtrise de tous
plutôt qu'une organisation qui soit
j'allais dire différentes ou multi
partenarial c'est un exemple mais nous
souhaitons surtout l'utilisation
éventuellement de la reconnaissance
faciale pour qu'elle le sénat a déjà
travaillé la commission des lois en
particulier nous souhaitons la
possibilité que le préfet au cas par cas
puisse dire aux opérateurs conserver vos
images pendant une durée d'un mois
qu'est la durée légale maximale de
manière pouvoir consulter ces images
croquées proposition du sénat ont
l'avantagé d'être facilement facile
directement mettre en place
[Musique]
si on a connu la vérité et c'est sur
cette situation c'est bien parce que le
sénat et la commission des lois et la
commission d'un fait la culture ont
exercé leur devoir de contre pouvoirs de
contrôle et c'est grâce à ce pouvoir de
contrôle des sénateurs et sénatrices de
ces deux commissions que nous avons pu
commettre ce rapport est finalement
connaître la vérité le parlement est
utile et le sénat en particulier il l'a
montré à plusieurs reprises notamment
dans les dernières semaines les derniers
mois qui se sont écoulés soit sur le
plan électoral soit sur le plan
sanitaire soit sur le plan sportif en la
circonstance donc exerçons au tour de
contrôle
[Musique]